the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or to view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
we're gonna start I'm gonna tell you why
I think that organization of your code
is like the bee's knees it's the coolest
thing ever
if you organize your code well then you
can end up having like not a horrible
player so so let's say let's say you
have I think lecture three robot release
is kind of long
like I release some code and it's long
look at all that stuff I mean it's
especially large when you have 16 point
font so that everybody can see from back
at the end but it's just too much so
here I'm gonna propose that you organize
your code into as you can see here on
the left many separate files so this is
a it's a tight house code he's one of
the he's one of the devs this year and
you can see here that his robot player
he's got you know his the package name
and he imports some things and right
after that he's got um he defines these
new types like bass player
headquarters player soldier player and
encampment player and each of these
things is part of bass player so you can
see here bass player is this public
abstract class that he defines here and
it has certain things that he wants to
use later and then later when he has
other when he has other players like an
encampment plane he can just say okay I
am going to call this public class
encampment player extends bass player
and now this guy has access to all of
this guy's methods and it's also located
in his own convenient place so I'm gonna
post some example that shows how to get
your codes separated in a convenient way
if you haven't done that before but
you've got so you've got your code
separated you know and you want to make
your life easy you don't you know you
don't want to code in a way that's gonna
make it hard for you to make changes and
make updates Steven arc Angele the one
battlecode I think two or three years
ago has posted on his blog a description
of the code of coding best practices
that enabled him to really do well in
battle code he did things like make sure
that things are in separate files that
they have sub packages
and he and that he worked on this
framework code most of the time that he
wasn't like trying to just mash out a
strategy he was like building systems
that he can reuse and use multiple times
he also made a rapid iteration system so
he could test his code against other
ways of running the same code and today
Aaron is here with me to set up a system
for sort of trading code between them so
we can work more efficiently so
according to Steven you know the he was
doing strategy only in the last week of
the competition I mean the rest of time
he was basically just writing you know
navigation code or something you know
something very basic and then he would
sort of figure out the strategy after
watching the tournaments like the Sprint
tournament a seeding tournament okay
just steal the strategy instead of
writing it yourself awesome yeah I guess
that's one way to do it so so I'm gonna
go ahead and I'm gonna switch on over to
Aaron and he's gonna show how he would
set things up to start sending me files
in the most efficient way hello I'm
Aaron the less effective lecture and I'm
going to tell you that the the most
efficient way to share files between me
and max is get spoiler alert let's get
so right so I have my directory
it's called user test but it's the same
it's the it's a battle code installation
the same as you guys have okay anyway I
have some stuff in here that I want to
share with max particularly particularly
something in the team's directory this
awesome player awesomer player and I
want max to have it so how do I get it
to them so first I made a bit bucket
account it's free it's similar to github
except the problem with github is if you
want a private repo you'd have to pay
for it so you probably end up using a
public repo which means anybody who can
guess your username just has access to
all your robots which makes it even
easier for them to steal your code in
strategies it's kind of silly bitbucket
gives you five a private
repo with up to five users we only give
you four users so a bit buckets perfect
so you make your bitbucket account and
then I want to make a repo for max and I
to share code so I'm gonna call it
battle code example I want it to be
private so that other teams can't steal
ur stuff it's gonna be get because
that's how I know how to use to me Java
I create it
so this repository Aaron this is going
to be you know on the internet and so
will will really be able to access it
from anywhere it's also started its own
backup system isn't it yep it back up
it's version intelligent cross-platform
etc it's like perfect yeah I was having
yesterday or the day before my computer
gave me a bunch of blue screens of death
I think like one of my memory sectors is
failing or something but I wasn't that
nervous because we have everything
stored online true story okay so alright
so get bit pocket goes ahead and gives
me the instructions so I'm basically
just gonna follow these instructions
I've already made the directory and I'm
already in it so I don't need to do this
but I want to do so right now it's not
the the installations not a git repo so
I'm gonna go ahead and make it one get
in it now it's empty and then it tells
me to add this thing as remote I'll do
that later okay
so right now it's an empty git
repository it's not very useful it's
because it's empty if I'd use git status
it tells me that it's that it's
basically empty does it does it tell me
that no it doesn't um forgot to do that
anyway yeah it tells me that there's all
these things that are on tract it's not
tracking anything so it said when I
initialized it here that it was empty so
even though there's a bunch of things in
this folder it doesn't really know or
care about them yet
because I haven't told them where they
are or what it should pay attention to
you and what it shouldn't pay attention
to so it's just empty that's why it's
labeled everything untracked because
that's not they're not yet tracked so
let me make some of these things trapped
tracked and by some I mean only the
awesomer player because that's the only
thing I want to give max right now so
I'm gonna do git add because I want to
add it to the list of things that's
tracked I go team slash awesome player
slash robot
okay cool now it's added so now if I
look at the status now I have one new
file it's not new I didn't make it so
it's not new with respect to the hard
drive but its new with respect to get
because git didn't know about it before
so and then these are still on tracked
so now to share it with max I have to
commit this change like right now it's
just been added but it's sort of
floating around in in space so commit
really solidifies it into a block of
changes that I can give to max so
initial commit just because that's the
best practices name for the first commit
yeah you can see here he's put a message
with it so we look at the commit logs
we'll be able to see his descriptions
what went on for all the changes all the
way back to the beginning and we'll have
all these things posted in my handy
dandy guide gosh I said it again and so
that so you don't have to like worry
about memorizing it right now you just
want to get the overview of like how
we're doing it and how much how many
millions of times more awesome it is to
do it this way than to email to one
another I should mention - a means all
like for everything and M means give a
message here with strings rather than
having to type it into an editor on
Windows if you leave out the MS which
you get notepad it's not that big of a
deal because it's you know it's just
notepad you just type it in and you hit
save and it's okay and you remember to
use the M search next time but on Linux
if you forget the M switch
most likely it'll give you vim which is
so complicated and arcane that it took
me many times before I even knew how to
close it so like escape acts : WQ or
something it's actually crazy I think
I've gathered that : q quits it and : W
saves but I think you heard like push s
to start typing it it doesn't even like
you you want to stay out of vim if
you're not initiated
okay got it
well I just use the M switch so I can
stay out of imp because it's only for
the initiated yes and I'll I will
discuss that eventually but for now the
only things you want to share are things
that you wrote yourself and are changing
yourself and I'll but I will discuss
more of that in the future so right now
I just want to share that one specific
file okay so I need to get it on - so
now it's committed I need to get it on
to here so I do this thing that it tells
me to do basically I'm going to add as a
remote like a thing that's not here it's
a remote it's somewhere else so the
server I'm going to add one called
origin just because origin is the
canonical name for this sort of thing
and then I follow the URL
you can't copy and paste into that no no
you can't no mine's better
yeah now we're he's using the mingw
shell to type these commands in if you
just put it in like Windows command
prompt I don't think it would work I'm
gonna use get back which you can get o
get you're using git shell with ya which
opens Windows PowerShell and I think and
you can get that online just by google
searching it did I don't know okay well
that means get remote
then I have to add it again oh cool
well there you go there's how you that's
how you remove or remotes two birds one
stone
yeah so to check to check what everyone
I have I do the - V you might be
familiar with like a verbose switch - V
so I have this look spelled correctly
cool now I push to it like you know take
my changes and push them to origin which
is the name I'd given to this URL to
this URL master is the master branch
it's gonna ask me for my password
because I haven't configured SSH
correctly but bitbucket has instructions
for setting this up so that your
computer's recognize each other and that
you don't need to type in the password
every time I haven't done it yet okay
now I looks like I successfully wrote
things to the server so match should be
able to get them oh no no he shouldn't
be able to because my repo is private
and nobody's allowed to access it but me
let me change that settings access
management and I want to give him read
and write but I don't trust him to
administer it so right it's good yeah I
have a certain Kenzi screwing up
jobs this was not included over to me
and now I need I have I wasn't before
and let's make some space here on the
left we have this is where I have
battlecode installed on the desktop and
I guess what I want to do is I want to
make this existing battlecode directory
the the main directory for the route for
my my github version of the thing that
he has mm-hmm yeah that's a technical
term so I'm gonna I'm gonna go into it
so now I'm in this directory and what
I'm gonna do is I'm gonna initialize get
so that now it knows that I'm interested
in using it in this folder and now now
that a minute I will do what was it get
AB remote or git remote add and I'll go
on to this website not this one not this
one tighter this one yeah this one I'm
just gonna hit refresh here is this it
battle code - example yeah ok so you
named it the same thing as you needin
love the previous one yep okay so I'm in
here and I can just right click and hit
paste because I have PowerShell so now
I've now I've added it and so I'll then
follow that up with a git pull mm-hmm
and that's gonna give me
oh it says it's not my I need a name
yeah uh you didn't name it I'm just a
name it yeah you just did get remote add
Evan you just add your song put the URL
but you didn't okay
I'll name it origin no the other way
around oh okay yeah so I'll name it
where do I name it and origin and then
the URL add origin and then that and
then the URL yep all right we'll have
this all written down so you'll have the
instructions in front of you when you do
it mm-hmm yeah no you should be able
okay so now I can get pull and this
should get me the stuff that he wanted
to give me now it may end up being a
problem
the Unipol specifically from
for gymnastics ah git pull origin mystic
yeah it for those of you who know get
already so I think it may be giving you
trouble because I may already have
awesomer player yeah just get rid of it
so I we're gonna pretend that I don't
have it
yeah so let's uh let's go back to
eclipse oh it's black what is that I
think Eclipse is very unhappy have you
ever had this yeah
okay where's the package is gonna these
are these are windows so we should
probably just restart both computers we
start both computers yeah and every
windows computer in the room every
alright right now let's see which is the
button that gets me the package back the
package inspector window opens
perspective show show view okay Pak Pak
Pak Pak Pak package ah got it
okay hey look it's not dead okay so
let's refresh it and now okay now it's
updated you see vintage it hasn't got
awesomer player there so that when I do
when I do this yeah that's that that
wrapped around but now I mean now I've
done this if I push it at five is that
gonna know did it not work it says here
already up to date already update I
think we broke it okay what are we gonna
do Aaron I don't know I don't know what
happened so you don't have awesome where
do you have lots of it I mean how laughs
awesomer without knowing I have awesomer
I'm that awesome let's see here
nope no there's nothing in there shall
we kill everything and start over it yep
right
doing it the right way you saw it here
first
Wow okay so bitbucket tells me idea yeah
make a new package it's send me that one
a new yeah like a new okay yeah I think
else something alright a different thing
okay let's go back to Aaron's computer
see are you so you made a super super
thing super awesome player a super
awesome player
yeah my goodness so now you're pushing
that on to the master and then once
that's done I'm gonna go back to me
right okay hmm okay so I'm going back to
my battlecode folder mm-hmm okay and now
I've already it's already got get in it
I'm already good to go
I've set up the remote by doing git
remote add origin and then the HTTP URL
that was available on the bitbucket
website well why don't you can get
status just to check I like that yeah
okay so I deleted a thing you know maybe
if I just pushed the bank and I deleted
that thing yeah maybe that was a bad
idea
well in any case we're gonna see what
happens maybe if I add it so that it's
tracking the thing that isn't there then
then that'll that'll improve matters mmm
why don't you just make the repo get oh
no but then you have to type in the URL
again yeah okay but let's do get pull
and let's let's see if it works okay
shall we I mean well yeah only only our
dignity from origin/master
oh well what happens if I just do it as
in is it's no good you got to configure
it before you do that it's an unpacking
objects I think it did things well a
bunch of objects but not I didn't know
where to put on my thing I didn't know
where to put them
well I split them somewhere now he says
one finally finished [ __ ] you it's fussy
I'm yeah we work together this is so
this is uh okay now the thing is there
yeah and if we wait ten minutes it clips
will start and then you can see that but
but while I'm doing that you could talk
about the next thing Oh
next thing oh yeah yeah there it is
super awesome
yeah that's pretty watch it it's super
good oh I should watch it yeah is it the
same as the other one no no it's mine
it's my special one oh it's your special
one yeah
oh my goodness you guys are in for a
real treat Aaron is a coding Beast I
gotta tell you I got to tell you since
this is the representation of his mic
and his capability right here ah let's
see here super awesome is the red fellow
and their use going capturing things
defusing mines oh no it's just a small
matter people rush strategy rush LP etc
change will change the game engine oh
I've already done it oh okay that makes
sense no I just didn't get them at the
latest version
yeah and wins all Manchester yep okay
anyway what
from from what what do you mean sorry I
don't understand
okay it's okay it's it's got to do with
it's got to do with corruption I'll
teach you sometime okay yeah I don't
know anything about that
of course so okay um so on so I do get
status which is always a good thing to
do like between every command that you
execute that you ask get to do before
you should do a status and after you
should do a status which means that
since I wanted to execute status to show
you I should have done get status three
times one for the before that gets that
is one exit to get status and one after
just so that you like get a really good
feeling for what the status is and you
should actually read it a bunch of times
so get status that's the command I type
on branch master masters a branch got it
well do branches in the lab yeah
untracked files okay it's a lot of
untracked files nothing added to commit
but uncharged files present okay nothing
added to commit means I haven't done
anything but there's untracked files
that's bad okay
so when I tell you status is really
important I mean it but if they call
this red stuff comes up every time you
type status
you're gonna start like not paying
attention to it so an important thing to
do is to tell git to ignore these things
that I never want to add so I just want
them to be ignored so what I do is I
tell I open up my favorite text editor
Emacs and I go to directory and I make a
file called dot get ignore and I no
longer exist okay anyway
not kidding man he makes us too clever
sometimes because he made this file
before the lecture in preparation and
then deleted it but Emacs was like are
you sure you didn't want to not have the
thing that you deleted and then looked
for later in a different place and then
he said yeah not empty okay cool
so have this empty file and to make it
ignore like this dot installation
information which I'm never going to add
to the repo I just type in dot
installation information and then to
make it ignore everything in the doc
folder because I'm never gonna have to
share that with Max cuz he has it from
the Installer just dude doc slash star
and then version dot text etc or I get
this handy to anyone that I've already
written and just copy all of it yeah
so now that I've made the dot git ignore
I saved it now the only untracked things
are the other teams so i could
specifically add those team slash
example teams slash macro player team
slash suicide player yeah right save
that get status Wow the the thing with
the squiggly is just another Emacs
folder I'll just ignore everything that
ends and squiggles anyway cool so now
the only thing that's untracked is the
doc get ignore so I'll just add the dot
get ignore because I do want to share
that with Mac so he doesn't have to go
through all that trouble that I just
went through and now if I do status I
get this really nice oh no now I have to
commit the fact that I've added the GUID
ignore I do the a.m. switch again a for
everything in the index and M for not
bringing up vim and pulling my hair at a
message
make a nice commit message so max knows
what this files for okay now if I do
status Wow words I get this really clean
status it even says that my working
directory is clean nothing to commit
perfect so I'll push that to max so he
can get it if he wants took my password
again one two three ABCD yeah I was
saying before this that it might be
convenient for us to just share the
whole of everything why wouldn't we do
that okay there's a lot of reasons not
to do it
okay couple of things you don't want in
your git repo anything that's platform
specific probably you don't want in your
git repo so right now I'm using Windows
and Max is using Windows but Steven
doesn't use Windows so anything that's
on our team like if I have a path that
is something like C you know backslash
users whatever that's gonna look like
nonsense when Steven checks it out so
anything platform-specific doesn't go in
the repo another thing you don't want in
the repo is stuff that we distribute by
we I mean we as battlecode people not we
as in this false battlecode team that
has the repo so we as battlecode people
release an installer that gives you
things like example funks player and
documents and stuff like that you don't
want those in the repo because let's say
I add example funks player to the repo I
check it in now this is I as the this
guy I check an example funks player max
is working on really complex navigation
code I have version 1.3 at Max's version
1.0 an example funk player the one that
I just checked in makes a one point
three specific function call that breaks
if you use it in one point out so I
check it in I upload it
max downloads my code expecting to get
you know some more navigation stuff that
he really needs but he also gets this
new version of example funks player that
so 1.3 specific function call breaking
and now his code won't compile at all
and now he has to interrupt the workflow
that he was like really deep into
navigation and I used to like what
where's this red X coming from and find
out that it's because it was in a
different version and he has to go
download it from battlecode org and then
install it again and then update and
then find out that the update doesn't
work on his computer and he has to fix
that like all of this and then in the
process for getting everything he knew
and about navigation so when he gets
back to it he's already forgotten so
it's just a pain so anything that we
update just get it from the Installer
don't put it in the repo there's no need
anything
binary don't put that in the repo
because it's inefficient git has really
good algorithms for compressing and
storing only meaningful things about
text so if I if there's a huge 1
megabyte text file and I change one line
get stores one line
none of those algorithms that it has
apply to binaries so if I upload a
binary and I change one line in the
binary like a binary meaning a zip
archive or a picture if I change one
pixel in the image get just test a store
both copies of the image which is
inefficient so if you like store a whole
our whole installer it's like 30
megabytes every time we update you'll
add another 30 megabytes so instead of
this like 500 kilobyte repo that Max and
I have right now if you kept going like
30 megabytes per installer you done with
500 megabytes bad not good and then
anything that's personal like project
settings you don't need them so what do
you put in the repo text documents that
you've created like source code or new
maps that you want or like a script or
all the incredible documentation that
you're gonna have for your players all
of that that can go in the repo cool
another one of these side prizes for
best documented code are we going to be
doing that this year Stephen make the
best best documented code side prize
this year probably probably something to
keep in mind keep those forward slashes
on your left ring finger
which is to say ready oh okay
mine is on the the left bracket because
I used to vorak alright so but it's no
it's the pinky how do you go all the way
over there with the ring I think yeah so
it's the same finger yeah pinky pinky
active coding okay cool
so then we just showed you an example
where I made a repo and put some files
in it and pushed to a server max made
his own repo pulled some stuff he got it
he could do the same thing now or he can
add files and push it and I can get them
and that's great but now we have to show
you what happens if Max and I both try
and change one thing the same thing so
and then we get a conflict it's really
scary and the reason why or it's a
reason that some people give up on git
but we're gonna navigate it it's gonna
be it's gonna be okay okay yeah okay so
let's go to my super awesome player okay
okay
and I think so you see like I have this
number capturing Channel yeah here I
think it's not big enough so I think you
should make it bigger well okay I'll
make it bigger but but you try and
explain it which is silly because you
don't know what it's for but I'll make
it bigger because I think that's
important all right
it's a radio channel so in case you
didn't get it making it bigger it's not
gonna change it yeah but anyway I'll
pretend okay so I did a status because
I'm about to execute commit so first I
did a status yeah getting getting the
hang of this okay now I'm gonna do a
commit because modified that's what I
wanted I wanted this player modify do
nice commit
okay I would use an exclamation mark
here but no exclamation marks in get
commit messages because bash handles
them incorrectly so they can't have
exclamation marks a so it's wonderful
all right I'm also pushing my change but
wait didn't work why updates who are
rejected because the tip of the branch
is behind remote counterpart pull okay I
think that what that means is that
because max pushed and I tried to push
to the same place as it it doesn't like
that because then it wouldn't know which
is the most recent version so it tells
me to resolve it by pull a lot of
commands when they give an error will
tell you what command to fix it with so
because I'm about to do a poll for
somebody to a status okay that's cool
and I'm gonna pull one two three ABCDE
oh no conflict look at that all caps
automatic marriage failed fix conflicts
and convinced result okay cool so team
super awesome Rober play robot player
Java not a conflict yeah it is okay so I
go to robot player dot Java oh man why
don't you do window preferences and
change your size to something non zero
and but I'm so excited about fixing fix
the conflict though is convicted
conflict appearance some conflicts have
been going on for thousands of years I
think it can wait then you go to Java
yeah okay it's only like another 16
windows you know and a text editor font
I know this is terrible
I know I know I have to do it every
lecture sixteen sixteen is a good number
oh but and let's make a bigger cuz you
have better resolution yeah okay cool
all right I've got tons of read didn't
work okay so the conflict markers are as
obvious as they can be really big loud
not part of any programming language or
obviously errors that you want to clean
up nice X's okay so this is head is the
head of my current stuff so that's gonna
be my copy and then this really long
number here is the hash name of Max's
commit so this is Max's thing max made a
comment and I changed the number and so
even though I know that all of my
changes are going to be superior to
anything that max wrote git doesn't know
that so since its conflicted it asked me
to fix it in this case I'll take what
max wrote and add it to mine and then
Liat not not the other way around by the
way yeah oh I didn't delete that okay
cool
so now it compiles probably still
doesn't beat the stupid rush player Opie
stuff in BA
I still doesn't it compiles and now I
have to tell git about the success so I
do a commit but before I do a commit
yeah getting it yet okay oh it deleted
awesomer player that's what max did on
his computer and we both modified robot
player Java pointing with point
my mouse I remember okay that's cool but
I fixed it
bless you so merge a success cake it's
close okay okay and then I pushed that
get full origin master I'm ready to push
this button and
yeah cool so that's a conflict
resolution which happens more than is
pleasant but it's not too hard to deal
with once you know you're doing because
github so smart about which lines were
changed and which weren't all right
so before max takes my changes and
starts messing around with them I'm
gonna just mention but not thoroughly
explain a bunch of super useful git
commands that are like if this wasn't
enough then if you go and look up these
commands on what they're for then you'll
be convinced that git is essential get
checkout well get log let me do this if
I show you the log which is something I
forgot to do if you do a status before
and after each command after you're done
with the second status do a log and log
tells you what's happened playing with
the mess okay write a bunch of thing
like this is the whole history of what
happened so get check out let's see you
take any of the any of these points in
time and set your repository like you're
working copy the copy on disk to what
was here so if I want to go to what
happened before the bigger numbers
commit I could check this out
and you get check out get branch
branches lets you have parallel
workflows it's really smooth I have this
document that I found online that
describes a really good really useful
way of using branches I'll discuss it in
the lab get reset hard so commit is like
a way of saying these changes are great
they're solid I like them keep them
anything you haven't yet committed can
be obliterated by reset hard so you
accidentally are MRF one of your players
or you make some change that
accidentally causes a divide by zero and
you have no idea how and you've spent a
half an hour looking for it you just
like you've given up and you just want
it gone get reset hard goes just
obliterates anything that's not
committed
stash does the same thing but puts it
somewhere and then you can take it back
off a stash pop get K summons a GUI
visualizer of the entire history just go
ahead and summon it there's our there's
our history there's some diffs what was
changed this was the merge
how it looks great for visualizing stuff
if you're not or even if you are good at
reading the terminal other commands diff
shows you the difference between two
commits like if I added comment to
message channel what I don't remember
that what comment was it I could do gif
git diff between 31d and the thing
before it o 31d was ambiguous one six
four nine he was ambiguous cool and then
I get oh that's where I deleted that's
where he deleted awesome player it looks
like he added awesome player which means
I probably specified in them in the
wrong order and then yeah so that's the
comment cool
that's diff revert makes the inverse of
a commit if you want to get rid of one
bisect lets you do a binary search
through your history to find a bug like
if you find out that it's like something
you find out like some cache you wrote
three weeks ago it doesn't work anymore
and like it worked when you wrote it but
doesn't work anymore but you haven't
worked on it at all so it's clearly like
something caused by something else and
you don't like it doesn't work this
commit doesn't work the commit before so
something you wrote somewhere in the
last three weeks broke your cache system
and you have no idea where it was and
get bisect lets you binary search
through your commit history to pinpoint
the location of the bug look it up it's
like too complicated to be explained in
30 seconds but it saved me a lot of time
once where I was looking for a bug for
like four hours
I gave up bisect let me find find it in
30 sec like 30 minutes and if I hadn't
well you know programmer time if you had
if I hadn't used bisect I really would
have just had to rewrite sections of the
engine like there was no way I was gonna
find it it was something real
dumb blame does what it sounds like so
if I do get blame on tells me who was
responsible for every line and the
evidence is clear the only person I can
play blame for super player super
awesome players loss is myself there's
like there's nothing here except me it's
all me
if max had changed some line like this
one or whatever if it wasn't checking
this encampment thing right and it would
have said max man and I could have
tracked it down but no it looks like
this file is all me and that's the only
person I can blame for my defeat
but anyway blame blame people it's great
know praising only blaming I actually
think there is a less negative version
of blame it does the same thing but use
blame okay do I need to cover we've
shown you examples and things we've
given you summaries I'm sure your mouths
are watering already I want to give a
little bit of a demo because the Sprint
tournament is coming up so soon Sprint
tournament submission deadline is Monday
so this is how you would submit so if
you haven't submitted already you you
right-click on the robot that you want
to submit and you go to export and I
think the instructions for this or
online yeah we're gonna switch to my
computer's my goodness that makes a lot
of sense so here we are I'm gonna
right-click on the robot that I want the
robot player that I want to submit this
is the package my export archive file
and I have to name it my team so I need
to actually change the package name to
team and then my team number in three
digits otherwise it doesn't work and
then I'll just export it to an archive
file and this would export it to the
desktop and then later I can go on to
battle code and I can say all right
upload my player and I'll be able to
choose the jar file from the desktop
where I've got it
and I can give it my own name and then I
could submit it and it'll tell me
whether it was compiled and worked
successfully so that's a complete
introduction entirely complete
introduction of get everything you ever
needed to know except for the things
that we're gonna go over in lab no
errands shaking his head there's a lot
to learn and it's all it only makes your
life easier it only helps except when it
doesn't so with that the next lecture is
gonna be on swarm and I'll also cover
some topics in debugging so you're gonna
watch like robots dancing around and
very mellifluous is that the right word
well then okay so they're gonna dance in
fancy ways
fancy pants dance and and that'll and
that'll take care of it so thank you for
coming to this lecture I hope you enjoy
the Thai food and I'll see you tomorrow